en el último vídeo aprendimos el teorema
del binomio y para situaciones como a
más b a la n iv en especial quien es muy
grande y ya no digamos más de 3
muchísimo más sería muy muy muy tedioso
hacer tantas multiplicaciones con
polinomios pero bueno cada quien podría
intentarlo pero lo que nos decía el
teorema del binomio es que a más ve a la
n
se puede expresar como la suma de k
igual a cero hasta n de las
combinaciones de n tomadas en k
a propósito así se llama el teorema del
binomio y es para encontrar los
coeficientes y de ahí viene su nombre de
la combinatoria entonces esto sería x
ala
copps no no no es x perdón a ver déjenme
borrar esto a ver pero digamos deshacer
otra vez es hacer en chispas parece que
no está funcionando y ahorita
a ver un momento y creo que ya lo logré
ya lo borde entonces serían las
combinaciones de en el tomado en cada
d
ala
n menos acá que está multiplicando a b a
la k cabe mencionar que la n es
constante y los demás coeficientes se
van calculando de las combinaciones en
el vídeo previo ya hicimos un ejemplo y
bueno la verdad parecía bastante tedioso
hacer las cuentas pero bueno hacer las
multiplicaciones está más complicado
pero qué tal si tú tienes facilidad en
calcular las casas tomadas de n y lo
haces de una manera rápida pero ahora te
voy a enseñar una forma mucho más fácil
podríamos decir que es una forma rápida
de calcular los coeficientes binomial es
después vamos a ver otra forma
maravillosa para calcular los que casi
va a parecer que lo memorizamos de hecho
conozco gente que si lo logra pero es
una forma rápida de multiplicar
cualquier binomio entonces cuál es mi
pseudo forma rápida de calcular esto en
sugerí en el vídeo anterior que estos
coeficientes son términos del triángulo
de pascal que es el triángulo de pascal
iniciemos con el número uno a veces
déjame ver si lo pongo no ahí está bien
ahí lo voy a poner en de hecho necesito
otro uno está entonces ahora pongo estos
dos uno si debajo de él pongo la suma de
los dos
esto es uno más uno es dos y luego bajó
a la izquierda y derecha el uno otra vez
lo repito mira y observé eso ya son los
coeficientes de a más b al cuadrado
y así los de arriba pues son a más ve a
la 1 y veamos que si funciona aquí
tenemos
al cuadrado más fina lo va a poner aquí
tendríamos una vez cuadrada más dos
veces a b más una vez b cuadradas ya
están los coeficientes
cambió el color agregó otro renglón y
hago exactamente lo mismo 1 y 2 da 3 2 y
13 y vuelvo a repetir el 1 en la
izquierda y la derecha y lo que tenemos
aquí son los coeficientes de hamás b al
cubo que ya habíamos obtenido y
reconocemos el patrón el primer
coeficiente que será uno por a al cubo
por ver la cero que es uno más en tres
veces este exponente lo voy a
decrementar entonces quedaría a cuadrada
por b y luego vendría pues más tres
veces a be cuadrada al final tengo uno
por a la cero que es uno ve al cubo y
esto fue rápido por lo que vamos a hacer
el siguiente
así que ponemos el 1
y después 13 me da 43 13 6 y ves esto
funciona muy bien me permite generar
coeficientes binomial es sin tener que
calcular los así que continuemos y 3 y
14 y después ponemos el 1 cabe resaltar
que podríamos tener de masa a una
potencia y los coeficientes serán los
mismos podemos obtener los de una manera
realmente rápida entonces a mars ve a la
cuarta y como ya debes de estar tú
imaginando y viendo cómo funciona esto
será una vez
le voy a cambiar de color para que sea
más claro 1 a la cuarta por ver la cero
que es 14 veces al cubo por ver al este
se les ve a la 1 luego será 6 veces
al cubo y como puedes observar a quien
en medio los exponentes son los mismos
que era un poco lo que esperaríamos
luego tendremos cuatro veces a b al cubo
y finalmente tendremos una vez a la 0 b
a la cuarta y bueno pues el acero es uno
el método rápido y vamos a continuar así
ponemos el
es el primero el 1 luego 14 me da 5 el
siguiente es 4 6 10 6 + 4 es otra vez 10
4 + 1 es 5 y luego tengo el 1 y
finalmente tenemos la expansión de los
coeficientes de a más b a la quinta
potencia
insisto este método funciona y es rápido
y te permite hacer desarrollos bueno de
potencias lo suficientemente grandes un
claro requeriría es bastante espacio
pero bueno con cierta facilidad podrías
trabajar la sexta la séptima potencia y
con cierta habilidad para el dibujo
podrías encontrar el desarrollo de los
coeficientes para cualquier potencia y
de hecho más rápido que hacer el cálculo
del oscar tomar o cnn por lo que
entonces no sería necesario hacer esto
pero ahora vayamos a otro método aún más
rápido este método te permitirá hacer
cualquier cálculo por ejemplo a + b a la
20 en prácticamente en tu cabeza claro
dependiendo qué tan hábil eres para
hacer cuentas en la cabeza pero vayamos
a ver este nuevo truco y te invito a que
lo pongas en práctica para que puedas
apreciar cómo es que funciona aunque más
que un truco si habláramos del triángulo
de pascal es un método alternativo que
me permite generar los coeficientes
binomial
y lo que estoy por mostrarte es otra
forma de calcular los coeficientes
binomial es voy a borrar la pantalla
creo que sería un excelente proyecto
investigar porque esto funciona voy a
continuar con un ejemplo concreto y esta
vez en vez de a&b voy a utilizar xvii
porque estás más acostumbrado a trabajar
el teorema del binomio con x
esta vez lo haremos x más a la décima
potencia estarás de acuerdo conmigo que
hacerlo con multiplicaciones me tomaría
todo el día o bueno tal vez 20 o 30
minutos siendo muy cuidadosos de no
cometer errores y también dibujar el
triángulo de pascal pues no sería una
idea muy sencilla así que cómo puedo
resolver esto veamos este desarrollo al
final tendrá 11 términos si iniciaremos
con x a la 10 g a la 0 y terminaremos
con x al hacer hoy a la 10
si iniciamos en cero y terminamos en 10
pues eso nos da 11 términos lo que voy a
iniciar es escribiendo pues básicamente
los números primero bueno entonces
escribo el 1 2 el 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 y el
11 más adelante verás que tal vez no es
necesario llegar hasta el 11 y nos
podríamos haber detenido en el 6 pero
bueno vamos a empezar a ver cómo se
desarrolla esto el primer término pues
era x a la 10 en el segundo término será
pues x a la 9 luego viene x a la 8 x a
la 7 x a la 6
luego x a la quinta a la cuarta al cubo
al cuadrado x a la primer potencia y
bueno x a la 0
ahora escribiremos los términos en que
éste a ver este está a la 10 y entonces
este va a la 10 voy a cambiar el color y
vamos a empezar pues está aquí que a la
cero que es 1
luego está a la 1
luego vendría al cuadrado y al cubo en
el siguiente sea la cuarta luego llega
la quinta vamos esté avanzando con la
sexta y la séptima luego tendríamos ya
la octava llega a la novena
y gas verde gms parar esto para que sea
más claro no vaya a parecer que se están
multiplicando ver voy a poner estas
barras de estos separadores no yo creo
que mejor con otro color sí que se vea
más claro y no nos vamos a confundir a
estos términos es son independientes
estamos tratando de hacerlo lo más claro
posible es bueno aquí también hace falta
separarlo y aquí también
ahora vamos con los coeficientes el
primer coeficiente siempre es 1 y la
regla para calcular los coeficientes va
a ser tomar el exponente multiplicarlo
por su coeficiente y dividirlo por su
posición o sea 10 por 1 es 10 dividido
entre 1 me queda 10 el siguiente se
calcula tomando el exponente de la equis
que en este caso es nueve veces su
coeficiente que es 10 entonces esto me
da 9 por 10 y dividirlo entre su
posición que en este caso pues es la
segunda posición es 12 así que 9 por 10
entre 2 me queda 45
y si vamos así vamos a ir continuando
tomamos ahora el exponente de la equis
que es 8 lo vamos a multiplicar por el
coeficiente que es 45 así que tenemos 8
por 45 dividido entre su posición que es
3 entonces esto nos quedan 8 por 15 lo
cual es 8 por 15 8.5 40 80 120 entonces
ya tenemos es 120 el siguiente
coeficiente así vamos a ir continuando
con cada uno de ellos voy a dividirlos
para que quede más claro las operaciones
corresponden a cada uno de los
coeficientes y ahora vamos con el
siguiente tenemos que es un 7 17 que
está multiplicando al coeficiente que en
este caso 120 7 por 120 dividido entre
su posición que es la cuarta entonces 7
por 120 entre 4 es lo mismo que 7 por 30
que es 210
y dividimos y tomamos el siguiente
exponente que en este caso va a ser el 6
que multiplica al coeficiente que es 210
dividido entre su posición que es la
quinta así que aquí escribo el 5 y 210
entre 5 el 5 en 210 cabe 42 veces 6 por
42 es lo mismo que 240 más 12 o sea 252
y una vez que estamos en el término
central en el del medio si el término
sexto es el que se encuentra en medio y
los demás coeficientes van a ser
similares como si fuéramos caminando en
dirección contraria bueno de hecho es la
definición de los coeficientes binomial
es que son simétricos y también podrías
calcular los pero eso quiere decir que
el siguiente pues será 210 el que sigue
le corresponde el 120 luego viene el 45
chispas que tengo poco espacio pero
luego estaría 1 con 10 finalmente el
último con 1
si escribo la solución lo que voy a
obtener es bueno te sugiero que lo
practiques para que desarrolles fluidez
en esto y en lo que voy a tener este
pues serán
x a la 10 más
10 veces x a la 9 porque más 45 veces x
al cuadrado
no es x perdón llega la octava más 120 x
a las 7 d al cubo más 210 x a la sexta
llega a la cuarta más 252 x a la quinta
ya a la quinta más 210 x a la cuarta a
la sexta y fuenlabrada media me quedé
sin espacio pero la idea se entiende
pero lo que queríamos mostrar es que si
tú haces las multiplicaciones de x más
de a la 10 lo más probable es que te
tomará todo el día
yo creo que haré otro ejemplo este de
otra manera en el siguiente vídeo